hi there you might have seen the recent
debate about two plus two
where everyone tries to weigh in the big
question being is two plus two equal to
four
or is two plus two equal to five and
for some reason the entirety of western
civilization
hangs in the balance right here
but everyone's missing the point
everyone's just kind of arguing about
this
but i want to point something out right
here just have a look at the
accounts arguing right here you know
james
eric you know what all of these have in
common
they're humans humans arguing about
fundamental questions
of the universe and culture what could
possibly go wrong so today we're
going to replace fallible weak-minded
humans
by ai we're going to build an ai that's
going to answer the question
what is two plus two now first thing
we're going to do is to import pi
torch if you're using tensorflow what's
wrong with you
come on just checking whether cuda is
available
cuda's basically shorthand in ai for
magic
so don't worry about that part now we're
going to
borrow quite a bit of code from the
pytorch example
because they've already implemented sort
of the same thing so the model we're
going to use
right here is going to be a generative
adversarial network now you might be
wondering hey
is it really smart to build ai on
something that's called
adversarial isn't that a little bit
dangerous
to that i say all right now so we're
going to grab the code from
over here first thing we need is the
model itself now the model is composed
of a generator and a discriminator the
generator is right here
let's plot that in here that looks good
look at that generator transpose
convolutions
norms release this is going to be
so artificial and so intelligent you
won't believe it
so the generator is responsible for
basically outputting
things in our case what we're going to
input a two
and a plus and a two and then the output
should be you know whatever the result
of that is
now as a data set we're going to use the
famous m
nist data set this data set is a very
challenging data set
it's a very large data set but i think
in order to tackle an important question
like this
we need to go for the creme de la creme
of datasets
so mnist is a dataset that contains a
lot of
these handwritten digits you might think
these are just numbers but these are
more than numbers these numbers have
a meaning so the computer just sees this
in numbers
but as a human you would see this right
here
see the zero this data set is
filled with digits a four
wow that's one of the things we need
look at that a nine
beautiful beautiful so our goal is going
to be to try to
make the network learn what two plus two
is
now if you know machine learning you
know that you need training data
so we need a labeled data set of
two plus two equals and then whatever
two plus two equals
so first we're gonna filter out all of
the examples
where that show at two so we need to
train this network right
so we need a number of training steps
you know in ai we
like to train for a lot of steps let's
just go for
nine thousand what we'll do is we'll
train nine thousand times
sixty four images and yeah is gonna
learn what two plus two
is all right so in each step we need to
create a batch
of training samples what we need is a
two
a plus and a two so for the twos we can
just select
uh two of the twos that we had before
now the plus is a little bit more tricky
so in order to make a plus
there's none in the mnist data set you
have to understand the mns data set is
also quite
old i think it was invented before the
plus sign was invented so that's not in
the data set
so we have to create a plus by ourselves
it's going to be hard but we'll give it
a try now i'm usually
way too dumb to use meshgrid but i'm
just gonna try
i mean you know what can go wrong okay
so as you can see
we're absolutely on the wrong track
right here
ladies and gentlemen the most beautiful
plus in the history of ai
all right so we got a plus and uh we got
uh all of our twos so now let's put them
together
look at that two plus two next sample
two plus two next sample two plus two
so our ai is going to be trained on data
samples just like
this now in order to make the generator
accept samples
like this we sort of need to change a
little bit because if we try to just put
this
into the generator probably it won't
work
you see there's an error the generator
is not artificially intelligent enough
yet so we need to
make it take samples so our samples are
of size
28 by 84 and what the generator right
now expects
is a sample of size 100 by 512
by 4 by 4. so you may notice we have
never made use of our batch size
uh so let's fix that right now so now
we're training in batches of images but
it's still
not cool for the generator so we need to
change the generator right here here
what's this good for nothing nothing
all right so it expects the input to be
of a certain size
and we're going to change that right
here we also don't want any
strides strides are for losers
and let's see where that gets us okay so
we made our generator accept
images that we want and produce images
of the size that we want now the entire
question here is
we need labels for our training data set
because who's to say what two plus two
is
and as i said usually i would outsource
this to grad students
but these are humans as well so
we're kind of in a pinch right here so
what we're going to do is employ a
heuristic
we're going to ask our machine
right here what two plus two for the
training examples
is okay so in python you can do this
by typing two plus two
and you know in this case that happens
to be
four but who knows so for each of these
training examples
we're going to um take the class label
which is provided in the data set
and we're going to take these class
labels and add them together and
whatever comes out is going to be the
label
for this in in this case it's it's for
you know but
it could be anything and we're just
going to
use these as training data for our model
so for that we're going to need the
label of the first sample
and the label of the second sample and
our final label is simply going to be
label 1 plus the label 2. as i said this
is a heuristic for training the ai
now usually in a generative adversarial
network or a gan for short
you'd have something that's called a
generator which we do
and you'd have something that's called a
discriminator now
i have my problems with this
discrimination there is no
space for discrimination in the ai field
so we're going to leave away the
discriminator right here i'm sorry i'm
sorry we're going to
directly go to the loss from the
generator
in order to calculate the loss we need a
reference and for that we're simply
going to go to
our data set with our label and find any
of the images that correspond
to that label so if our heuristic
if our oracle says two plus two is equal
to nine
we're just going to invert our data set
get a nine and put that
as a training output okay okay so if we
look at one of the labels that
just happens to be a four in this case
um but we're going to go through the
entire
number of 9000 steps and in each steps
we'll train
64 of these different combinations of
two plus two
and we'll give one of the labels each
time and we'll see what the
um ai comes up with for that we need a
loss now the loss we're going to use
here is going to be the
l2 loss now there's some controversy but
uh you know it is the most powerful loss
proven
and we have to employ the most powerful
tools
so let's do that so our loss here at the
beginning is
509 now that's a lot of loss
that's a big loss we need to get that
loss down
and to do that we need one of these
optimizers now optimizers are kind of
the secret workhorses of ai
and people don't talk about them enough
i wish there was like a field of
research that deals with
optimizers like could be called
optimization or something like this i'm
not sure i just
i just think it would make a lot of
sense
so my favorite learning rate is uh three
e
minus four just because it contains all
of the different
uh things like a letter and the dash
and that seems like a pretty good thing
to do so we're going to use adam here as
an optimizer
adam i know i don't know adam personally
but uh i know a couple of his friends
and
they tell me he's pretty good so you
know
it's gonna go zero grad and i'm dumb
so i need to look up how to use an
optimizer and boom
okay okay so it's again a four don't
don't worry about this
i think this is it this is it this is ai
history
right here right now
for five steps ten steps all right i
have waited
and waited and waited and it's finally
done
we have now trained the generator to
calculate
what two plus two equals from the
training data set so now we
actually need to ask it what is two plus
two and of course we can't ask
it a sample that it is already seen we
need to take a
a new sample from the test set as
is customary in machine learning so
let's get the mnist
test set now the test data set consists
of images
as does the train data set but the model
has never
seen the test data set before this is a
property we call
generalization so let's find two nice
twos all right that's the first one okay
these are two nice
twos let's put them together okay so
this is going to be our input
to the generator okay so i'm putting
the test sample here into the generator
that is trained
and i've labeled the output in all caps
just to
tell the model that this is a really
important computation i'm just going to
run this cell
for a couple of times just to make sure
that generator is in fact
very sure about how important that is
all right
i think that's enough let's have a look
at that final output
i'm shaking are you ready for ai history